that was an absolutely crazy game on ice  and is draw a fair result at the end  yeah i mean when both players played  this bad i think draw is fair  it was a crazy game uh of course the  crucial thing was that i had seconds  when i was up a queen it's completely  winning i think at that point um  but maybe i gave this check on f6 for no  reason but i just had  like that literally if i had like 30  seconds maybe but i had like seconds  going down and i just made some move  not close on time but it's crazy to  actually see those kind of back and  forth games end with a draw were you  both happy at that point  i don't know i think both unhappy  probably  but i have to check  how many missed opportunities i had  maybe it was not that easy i don't know  i have to see good luck to you thanks